as we've seen tonight every artistic
contribution is vital to the process of
making a movie as actors we work very
closely with hair and makeup teams
they're our friends there are therapists
in fact Jennifer and I have had the
pleasure of being personally transformed
by several of the nominees but we wish
them all good luck even the ones we
haven't worked with because we may end
up in your chairs too
the astonishing
work these artists
here displayed their profound skill and
Technical expertise
these films wouldn't be the same without
them and we can thank these gifted
collaborators for always helping us look
the part
here are the nominees for achievement in
makeup and hairstyle All Quiet on the
Western Front I can mirka and Linda
eisenhanova
the Batman Naomi Don Mike Moreno and
Mike Fontaine
Panther wakanda forever Camille friend
and Joel Harlow
Elvis Mark Coulier Jason Baird and Aldo
senoretta
the whale Adrian Moreau Judy Chen and
Anne-Marie Bradley
and the Oscar goes to
the whale
[Applause]
Judy Chen and Anne-Marie Bradley
the team transformed Brendan Fraser into
the whale through the first time use of
All Digital prosthetic makeup for a
major feature this pushed Fraser's
weight into the severest extreme without
covering his face and allowing for his
emotional range of expression
[Applause]
thank you
thank you so much uh
uh would like to thank the amazing
makeup artists that worked with us to uh
to create the character of Charlie
so Kathy C Chris Gallagher Michelle
bougie in the shop the entire makeup
team our director Darren aronowski
pushed us to new heights thank you
our amazing actor Brandon Fraser over
there
thank you
our producer the studio a24 and the
academy thank you so much
[Applause]